President Trump is threatening
a government shutdown
over funding
for his border wall
just as he faces
the most serious legal peril
of his presidency.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's worth remembering
that when 2018 began,
we didn't know anything
about illegal hush payments
to porn stars, a secret resister
inside the Trump administration,
or the fact that Rudy Giuliani
always looks like he just sat
on a box of thumbtacks.
When the year began,
Republicans controlled
all three branches of government
and they were celebrating the
passage of a corporate tax cut
to line the pockets
of millionaires.
And to take a victory lap
at the time,
Trump turned
to his creepiest aide,
senior adviser Stephen Miller.
[ Thunder crashes ]
[ Witch cackles ]
-You rang?
-Miller decided to go on TV and
make the President look good --
A, by comparison, and, B,
by calling him a genius.
-On the campaign,
I had the chance to travel
all across the country
with the President,
and I saw a man
who was a political genius.
The reality is is the President
is a political genius.
All these so-called political
geniuses in Washington,
whether it be at the
big lobbying firms or --
-The only person who's called
him a genius in the last week
is the President.
-Because it happens to be
a true statement.
-Ugh.
Stephen Miller is
the only person on Earth
who'd be less creepy
if he wore a hockey mask.
But, hey, maybe
some of Trump's supporters
still thought he was a genius,
and yet in the almost 12 months
since that comment,
Trump has rambled at length
about how people in Finland
rake the floors of the forest,
left an umbrella outside
when he couldn't figure out
how to close it,
got on Air Force One with
toilet paper stuck to his shoe,
and said this about a hurricane.
-They haven't seen anything
like what's coming at us
in 25, 30 years, maybe ever.
It's tremendously big
and tremendously wet.
[ Laughter ]
-Tremendously big
and tremendously wet
sounds like something
Stephen Miller would say
about Donald Trump.
As we've learned this year,
the President is just
a weird, weird man.
He's like a space alien
with a head injury
who just took
his first bong rip.
"It is a pleasure to meet you,
fellow human.
I am enjoying the traditional
Earth greeting of shaking hands
for exactly one full minute.
And now let us all
display our patriotism
by engaging in the
customary hugging of the flag.
I am normal!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
But you'd think
a political genius
could at least figure out a way
to deliver on the one thing he
repeatedly told his supporters
he would absolutely do,
and that's build the wall.
And yet today, Trump threatened
the very real possibility
of a government shutdown
because he didn't get any money
for the wall.
In fact, it's finally starting
to dawn on his supporters
that the wall
is never going to happen,
and they are
very upset about it.
-Democrats are
going to win on this.
There will be no money
for the President and his wall
this time.
-Not a penny!
Forget wall.
Think border security.
-I think that not funding
the wall is going to go down
as one of the
worst, worst things
to have happened
to this administration.
Forget Mueller. The wall, the
wall, the wall has to be built.
And this was a scandal
that it hasn't been built.
-Well, it's very sad.
We needed the wall.
-That's a real fight,
and I don't know
that he minds dragging it out
for a while.
-Is it something
he just needs --
-...series of
two-week agreements.
-It is something he just
needs to give up on, though?
-Wow, man. They're talking
about the wall
like they just lost a pet.
Trump's gonna have to have
a special chat
with the Fox & Friends.
"Mr. Trump,
where'd the wall go?"
"It went to a farm upstate
to live with
all the other walls."
Because he knows he's never
gonna get any money
for his wall.
Trump has been lying
and claiming
he's already building it
just by putting up some fencing
with existing money.
But now supporters
are starting to figure out
that's also a lie.
Here's Trump lying about the
wall followed by a very confused
Laura Ingraham trying to
figure out what he means.
-A lot of wall has been built.
We don't talk about that.
But we might as well start
because it's building --
It's being built right now.
Big sections of wall.
And we will continue that.
-Uh, wh-- I must have missed
the wall being built.
What wall?
Where's it being built, Tom?
-I think what he means
is they're upgrading
certain parts of the wall.
-That's not a wall.
Stop saying it's a wall.
There's no wall.
If you want a wall,
say, "We don't have the wall."
I know it's bad
because he made the promise,
but they're not
building the wall.
-Wow!
She went through all five stages
of grief in five seconds.
It's like watching someone
realize they're in the Matrix
in real time.
"This isn't real!
None of this is real!"
So, today, Trump,
the political genius,
said at the last minute
he would not sign a deal
to keep the government open,
and in response,
outgoing House Speaker Paul Ryan
scrambled to find a way
to get him money for his wall,
which is a fitting end
to Paul Ryan's career.
Ryan had spent all year
loyally serving Trump
and ignoring
his many abuses of power,
even openly admitting
he doesn't pay attention
to Trump's scandals.
-Mark Sanford yesterday,
speaking on
the Stormy Daniels story,
said allegations of hush money
are a big deal.
I guess first question is,
do you agree
with that characterization?
-I haven't put a second
of thought into this.
It's just not
on my radar screen.
-This must bother you.
"Access Hollywood,"
Stormy Daniels, Karen McDougal.
At a certain point,
it must be embarrassing.
-Well, look,
I didn't read the article.
-Is it appropriate,
in your view,
for the White House to invoke
executive...and deny --
-No. I'm not familiar with
exactly what happened yesterday.
I've been a little busy
with some other tasks.
-Man, Paul Ryan might be
a bad House Speaker,
but he'd be a great roommate.
"Hey, Paul, my friends
are coming over to watch
the UFC fight, and then
my punk band's gonna practice."
"That's cool.
I'll be busy with other tasks."
Yesterday in his
farewell address,
Ryan decried what he called
our broken politics,
but Ryan is the one
who spent two years
ignoring Trump's many scandals
and actively praising Trump
in truly absurd ways,
like when the GOP passed
their corporate tax cut.
-Something this big,
something this generational,
something this profound
could not have been done
without exquisite
presidential leadership.
-I'm sorry. Did you just
use the word "exquisite"
to describe Donald Trump?
You're talking about him
like he's an art installation
at the Guggenheim.
He's not exactly a Picasso.
I mean, look at him.
If he looks like anything,
he looks like he was painted
by Edvard Munch.
[ Laughter ]
Although, you know what?
He'd fit right in
in that Salvador Dalí painting
with all those melting clocks.
Watching Ryan frantically
try to scrape together money
for Trump's border wall
is a fitting way
for his career to end.
Ryan used high-minded rhetoric
about the importance
of our institutions
while Trump degraded
those institutions.
For example,
Ryan had nothing to say
when the President's lawyer,
Rudy Giuliani,
went on TV and literally said
that truth isn't truth.
-When you tell me that,
you know, he should testify
because he's going to tell the
truth and he shouldn't worry,
well, that's so silly because
it's somebody's version
of the truth, not the truth.
He didn't have a conversation --
-Truth is truth.
I don't mean to go, like --
-No, it isn't truth!
Truth isn't truth!
The President of the United
States says, "I didn't --"
-Truth is a truth. Mr. Mayor,
do you realize what --
This is gonna become a bad meme.
-No. No, no.
Don't do this to me.
-In every interview,
every interview,
Rudy sounds like a grandpa
whose adult children
just put him in a nursing home.
"Don't do this to me!
I can live on my own!
Just get me a stair lift!"
Also, can we go back
to this part real quick?
-This is gonna become
a bad meme.
-Chuck Todd, why are you talking
to this guy about memes?
He doesn't know what a meme is.
Rudy probably things a meme
is one of those guys
who pretends to be trapped
behind an invisible wall.
Well, truth is truth,
and now the truth
is starting to catch up
to Rudy and Trump
like when we learned recently
that Trump
and his former lawyer,
Michael Cohen,
had lied about plans to build
a Trump Tower in Moscow
during the 2016 campaign.
After insisting that he never
had any business deals
in Russia,
Trump went back on all that
and admitted he did try
to build a Trump Tower in Moscow
but insisted it wasn't
that big a deal.
-It was during
the early part of '16
and I guess even before that.
It lasted
a short period of time.
I didn't do the project.
I decided not to do the project.
So I didn't do it. So we're not
talking about doing a project.
We're talking about
not doing a project.
We decided -- I decided
ultimately not to do it.
There would have been
nothing wrong if I did do it.
If I did do it, there would have
been nothing wrong.
That was a project that
we didn't do, I didn't do.
It was just reported very well
by Catherine Herridge,
who's a terrific reporter
on Fox.
She talks about a letter
that he signed.
I don't even remember it.
And it specifically
talks about this deal.
-Trump only knows three words,
and then when he runs out,
he starts drawing invisible
squares with his hand.
I guess you could call him
a French meme.
The Trump Tower project
was apparently so serious
that there was actually
an official letter of intent
signaling that Trump
wanted to go forward with it.
Now, you heard Trump there say
he didn't really know
anything about that letter.
And on top of that,
Rudy insists that the letter
wasn't a big deal
for one important reason.
He told CNN there was
a letter of intent to go forward
but no one signed it.
Oh, come on, Rudy.
That's your excuse?
No one signed it? What's next?
"He tried to mail it, but he
doesn't know Putin's address."
[ Laughter ]
Well, you will never guess
what happened.
This week, we found out
that Rudy was either lying
or very wrong when he said
no one signed the letter.
-This is the letter of intent
for the proposed
Trump Tower Moscow.
All right?
It is signed by Donald J. Trump.
It's a lot of pages, man,
with a lot of detail
about what they wanted
and how they wanted it
and how he'd be paid.
And there's his signature. Okay?
-So Trump lied
about the letter, too.
Mr. President, let me put this
in a way you'll understand.
You went on TV and said
you didn't sign the letter.
But now the feds might bust down
your door and put you in a cell,
and then we'll be stuck
with President Mike Pence.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So...
how did Rudy explain the fact
that Trump's signature
actually does appear
in the letter?
He said he was confused.
-Rudy Giuliani is commenting
to our Dana Bash, a new comment.
I'm seeing that he was wrong
if he said that the President
didn't sign this letter.
He said,
"I haven't seen the quote,
but I probably meant to say
that there was never a deal,
much less a signed one."
So some very, very confusing
statements from Rudy Giuliani.
You don't want a lawyer,
especially one working for the
President of the United States,
who is going to say two things
completely opposite
of one another.
-You wouldn't,
but that's exactly
the kind of lawyer
Donald Trump wants.
He thinks he's
psyching everyone out
by putting a crazy person on TV.
Trump watched "Lethal Weapon"
and thought,
"I want a lawyer like that!"
Every Rudy interview
basically goes like this.
-Joining me now
is the President's attorney.
-Yeah, you want to see crazy?
-Trump is in serious
legal jeopardy
just as Democrats prepare
to take over the House,
and he's hoping he can
salvage his presidency
by threatening a shutdown
over his wall.
I'm not saying he's scared,
but his pants are...
-Tremendously wet.
-This has been "A Closer Look."